لن تتركنا امريكا وستفي بوعدها.
هكذا قالتها كييف والاتحاد
الاوروبي يقدم وعودا للاوكرانيين
تفوق وعود الامريكان. ويا لكثرة
تلك الوعود التي كسرتم رؤوسنا
بها. فالوعد دين غير مدفوع كما
يقولها العرب. بينما واشنطن توجه
امرا بسرعة لتغيير الاستراتيجية
الحربية على ارض المعركة. وحشود
عسكرية ضخمة تتجه صوب روسيا.
والامريكان حقيقة مواجهة الدب
الروسي ويعترفون بها. فعن اي
اعتراف يتحدثون والناتو يعلن عن
الدول التي تدعم الحرب ويكشف عن
اسلحة نوعية قد تحسم الحرب في
اوكرانيا في الايام القادمة
والسودان يصدر مرسوما دستوريا
بشأن الدعم السريع والبرهان يحط
رحاله في قطر. ومجموعة عشرين
تكافئ الاتحاد الافريقي الجابون
يقوم بخطوة غير متوقعة الرئيس
المعزول. واشنطن وثقة الاوكران.
اوكرانيا لا تملك شيئا في هذه
الحرب غير الثقة بالولايات
المتحدة ووعودها. والثقة
الحقيقية امر نادر في ايامنا هذه
يا سادة. وها هو نائب وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني الكس ميلنك
يقول انه واثق من مواصلة
الولايات المتحدة لجهودها في دعم
بلاده خلال حربها مع روسيا.
مضيفا ان اوكرانيا تملك ترسانة
من الداعمين لخمسين دولة حول
العالم. وانهم يقدمون ما في
وسعهم لتعزيز القدرات الاوكرانية
في مواجهة العدو الروسي. هل تقوم
هذه الدول بما ذكر من **** حقا?
ام انه يستدرجها بكلامه المعسول?
اما في الجانب الغربي فالامر
يتغير من حين لاخر. فالدول
الغربية ترى انها بحاجة لتبني
استراتيجية جديدة ما بعد الهجوم
المضاد الذي تشن اوكرانيا على
الجيش الروسي. كانت تريد ان
تنتصر في الحرب على روسيا. ووفقا
لصحيفة فورنا فيرس فعلى
الاوكرانيين التأكد من ان الغرب
على استعداد لدعمهم في حربهم من
اجل هزيمة روسيا لكن ماذا لو لم
يستطع الاوكران هزيمة روسيا وهو
ما يحصل. الاجابة تأتي من موسكو
التي اكدتها مجددا بان الغرب
يريد القتال حتى اخر اوكراني فيا
لها من رغبة. وهنا خرج الرئيس
الاوكراني فولوديمرزالينسكي خلال
لقائه في كييف وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن محذرا من
شتاء صعب ينتظر الاوكرانيين.
واضاف زلانسكي ان كييف ستجتاز
الشتاء مع شركائها الغربيين
سويا. بدوره اكد بلينكن ان الدعم
الامريكي سيستمر على المدى
الطويل لجعل اوكرانيا قوية.
مضيفا ان واشنطن تريد ضمان ان
تكون اوكرانيا قادرة على ردع
خصومها على المدى البعيد. وليس
مجرد النجاح في هجومها المضاد.
بالمقابل قال الكرملين ان الدعم
الامريكي المقدم لكييف لن يغير
نتيجة ما سماها العملية الروسية
الخاصة في اوكرانيا. لكن مهلا
مهلا عن اي نجاح يتحدث بلينكن
فيما تقول مجلة نيوز ويك
الامريكية ان القوات الاوكرانية
تفقد مواردها على الجبهة
الجنوبية وهي غير قادرة على شن
اي عملية واسعة النطاق ضد شبه
جزيرة القرم الروسية. واضافت ان
كييف لا تمتلك او الطائرات التي
تحتاجها للحفاظ على سيطرتها على
البحر بمفردها. والعين
الاوكرانية تروق الدعم الغربي
كالعادة. لتتخذ امريكا خطوة
خطيرة لطالما حذرت منها موسكو،
وذلك باعلان وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن عن تسليم
الاصول التي تمت مصادرتها من
الاوليجرشيين الروس لاوكرانيا
لاول مرة. والتي ستستخدم الان
لدعم المحاربين الاوكرانيين.
اليكم المصدر كما نتصفحه امامكم
في موقع سبوتنيك العالمي. ليأتي
الرد الروسي على لسان المتحدث
باسم الرئاسة الروسية دميتربسكوف
الذي قال ان كل حالة من حالات
المصادرة غير القانونية لاية
اموال واصول روسية في الخارج
ستتسبب بدعوى قضائية جدية ان
موسكو لن تترك هذا الامر يمر
ببساطة. فهل وصلت الرسالة
ليستدرك المحلل العسكري الامر
بقوله ان الولايات المتحدة لن
تدخل في نزاع عسكري واسع النطاق
مع روسيا لان الجنرالات
الامريكيين يدركون عدم قدرتهم
على تحقيق النصر. وشدد على انه
لا في سوريا ولا في اوكرانيا ولا
حتى في اوروبا لا تملك الولايات
المتحدة فرصة لهزيمة روسيا وشهد
شاهد منهم. ونحن لم نأت بشيء من
عندنا. ليدخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
الخط. فقد افاد معهد كيل
للاقتصاد العالمي ان دول ومؤسسات
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعدت بتزويد
اوكرانيا بضعف ما وعدت به
الولايات المتحدة من مساعدات في
حال احصاء مساعدات جميع الدول
الاوروبية فان حجم المساعدة
الموعودة يصل الى مائة وستة
وخمسين مليار يورو وفق وكالة
نافوستي. وبينما يحاول
الاوروبيون دعم اوكرانيا على
المدى الطويل. وزلنسكي يهدد
الاتحاد الاوروبي باللجوء الى
القضاء. وذلك في حال تمديد
القيود على استيراد المنتجات
الزراعية الاوكرانية. وخطب
زلنسكي بشكل منفصل المفوضية
الاوروبية قائلا ان اساس اوروبا
هو المنافسة الحرة والوفاء
بالوعود. وفيما يخص المعارك قال
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ان
دولا عديدة مثل هولندا
والدانمارك والنرويج اعلنت
استعدادها لتسليم اوكرانيا
طائرات من طراز اف ستة عشر. والى
الميدان حيث اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانية مقتل سبعة عشر شخصا
واصابة اكثر من ثلاثين اخرين في
قصف روسي استهدف السوق المركزي
في منطقة دونيسك. وقد ندد الرئيس
الاوكراني بالقصف وقال انه يجب
الحاق هزيمة بروسيا في اقرب فرصة
ممكنة لمنع تكرار مثل هذه
الهجمات. والعودة على المصدر كما
هو موضح امامكم. اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانية سبعة عشر شخصا واصابة
اكثر من ثلاثين اخرين في قصف
روسي استهدف السوق المركزي في
منطقة دونيتسك. وقد ندد الرئيس
الاوكراني بالقصف وقال انه يجب
الحاق هزيمة بروسيا في اقرب فرصة
ممكنة لمنع تكرار مثل هذه
الهجمات. هذا وقال ضابط استطلاع
في اللواء رقم مائتين التابع
لاسطول الشمال الروسي والذي يعمل
ضمن مجموعة القوات الجنوبية انه
تم رصد حشد قوات اوكرانية كبيرة
في المناطق القريبة من ارتيمو
بيسك ووفقا له يتم تعزيز القوات
الاوكرانية المتواجدة على خطوط
التماس في تلك المنطقة بكميات
كبيرة من الذخيرة. في المقابل
اعلنت الدفاع الروسية عن تدمير
مائة وسبعة عشر موقع تمركز لقوات
كييف وتحيد اكثر من سبعمائة
وخمسين عسكريا واسقاط احدى
واربعين مسيرة وكالعادة المصدر
هو من يتحدث. الاحداث والتطور
اصدر رئيس مجلس السيادة
الانتقالي في السودان الفريق اول
ركن عبدالفتاح البرهان مرسوما
دستوريا قضى بحل قوات الدعم
السريع وامر البرهان القيادة
العامة للقوات الشعبية المسلحة
والامانة العامة لمجلس السيادة
والجهات المعنية الاخرى بوضع
القرار موضع التنفيذ. هذا وحط
البرهان رحاله في دولة قطر مع
بعض من قادته لاجراء مباحثات
سياسية. وافقت مجموعة دول
العشرين على منح العضو الدائمة
للاتحاد الافريقي في اجتماعها
المقبل في نيودلهي بحسب ما نقلت
شبكة بلومبرج نيوز. واضافت
الشبكة نقلا عن مصادر مطلعة ان
هذه الخطوة ستمنح التكتل
الافريقي الذي يضم خمسا وخمسين
دولة نفس الوضع الذي يتمتع به
الاتحاد الاوروبي من تسميته
الحالية المنظمة الدولية المدعو.
بشكل مفاجئ ورغم اتهامات الفساد
الموجهة اليه اعلن الرئيس
الانتقالي في الجابون الجنرال في
بيان بثه التليفزيون الحكومي ان
الرئيس المخلوع علي بونجو حر في
التنقل ووضعت السلطات الانقلابية
في الجابون بونجو رهن الاقامة
الجبرية منذ ان اطاح به الجيش في
الثلاثين من اغسطس الماضي.